you know i just feel like snoop is just
what he does
even embracing the youth like i feel
like him him and e4 do an amazing job at
embracing jordy for sure yeah the youth
and i think that's been pivotal in their
longevity
i think it's very hard to say the other
thing too is i think if you're snooping
you're e40
you're probably very um who the [ __ ] is
gonna say no
to that nobody like if e40 calls you and
it's like yo get on my album
you're not gonna say no because then you
look crazy i've heard i've heard a story
of a rapper who blew a shot with 40.
but like like just did not get in the
verse back or some [ __ ] like like what
are you doing what [ __ ] says no
like maybe drake nah he might
nah but nah
drake not turning down you think drake
would say no to snoop or 40
maybe [ __ ] no drake would be out of his
rabbit ass smile i'll tell him
then e40 need to get that drake verse
if you know anything you're going to say
no you might as well give me and drake
not saying no to e40 or snoop dogg
i hope not i mean i mean [ __ ] how could
he be the only one
maybe maybe hove or andre is not saying
no
andre three thousand might say no yeah
but that's different
three stacks don't rap i'm saying
he don't even rap like